das hier sind unsere helden aus italien
zwei ärzte und zwei pfleger der
uniklinik jena waren zwei wochen lang in
süditalien in der nähe von neapel im
einsatz
die angaben über die landesregierung ob
wir bereit wären italienische schwer
kranke patienten zu betreuen die kopie
19 erkannt sind und wir uns überlegt
haben ob es vielleicht auch von anderen
einsatz gäbe nämlich mit personal von
uns nach italien zu gehen und dort zu
helfen mehreren kann und wenn auch zu
helfen und werden das große glück
relativ schnell dann immer kurze zeit
vier personen ausfindig zu machen die
bereit war nach italien zu gehen ich
glaube das wichtigste war einfach mit
dabei gesagt also wir haben regulär
mitgearbeitet haben in den schichten
mitgearbeitet wir waren in die isolation
bereich und haben da einfach gehalten
und mit gekonnten der 39 jährige florian
prechter ist oberarzt mit dabei waren
außerdem die 24 jährige pflegerin
valeria di an francesco ihr kollege
nelson rivera 29 jahre alt und der 34
jährige arzt gerne ski tag nach der
rückreise mussten die vier selbst in
quarantäne
doch zwei bisher durchgeführte corona
tests waren negativ